yawn burning is going home
the 33 year old politician often has to
cover the entire city in a day and to do
so he often travels by car not his own
though he shares it with 40 others
opinion Auto escape and I've never had
my own car but there are moments when
it's practical sometimes you want to
transport things which is difficult with
just a bike and backpack that's when I
get a car I'm a regular now I use it for
things I would never have before
foreigners could have fed us Phillips
knows you used to have to return the car
to the pickup point but now you can drop
it off anywhere an app shows where the
nearest available car is you do a quick
inspection and if you're satisfied with
how the previous customer left it you
jump in and drive away
it cost burning about 30 cents per
minute to use the car he doesn't have to
worry about filling it up cleaning it
repairs or even parking fees the company
takes care of that once burning drops it
off it's out of his hands if I want to
go out at night for a beer
I can drive there and go home on the
train and I don't have to go back the
next morning to pick up my car I just
leave my house look up the nearest car
on my phone drive it and then just leave
it on the wall so I'm stressed I meet up
with most know kinda zorga men behind
burning can choose the car that suits
him best whatever the situation sunshine
rain parking in small spaces or big
shopping trips car sharing is catching
on in Germany the number of users has
doubled in the past three years - more
than half a million the status of car
ownership has also changed says mobility
expert Frank Volta owning your own car
has lost the significance for the
current generation it's more about being
able to use one in cities there's
nothing special anymore about driving a
certain brand of car the younger
generation would rather spend their
money on travel or on a new smartphone
if they do buy a car it's usually much
later in life so the car industry is now
selling mobility instead of just a
physical product
companies want to bring car shares to
the brand the traditional days of car
ownership are indeed changing
it's but things will get easier we're
not going to go crazy dealing with five
different price ranges from eight
manufacturers there'll be one system for
the city that means that mobility will
be better and that owning your own car
will become rarer in urban areas
it seems to be a win-win situation
but car-sharing still only makes sense
for people who live in big cities and
for those who have to drive every day or
drive long distances it can get
expensive quickly but for burning it's
the perfect solution simple flexible and
economical I know stressful having your
own car repairs parking gas with car
sharing I don't have those problems I
get my car whenever I need it it's
usually someplace close and ready to go
and that's how yon burning will continue
to travel driving cars that don't belong
to him just so long as there's one
available